hi i'm patton oswalt and I'm doing a
wired autocomplete interview of an open
book anything you need to know it's
probably online first question is does
patton oswalt oh this could get spicy
the number-5 response does did patton
oswalt
stab snoop dogg no i don't have the
reach does patton oswalt cook yes if you
like SpaghettiOs I cook does Patton
Oswalt have a podcast I don't when I do
it'll probably be called generally
Patton does Patton Oswalt narrate the
Goldbergs oh he does even when he's not
being paid does Patton Oswalt have
siblings I have a younger brother Matt
Oswalt funnier than me on Twitter
bastard
next question is Patton Oswalt in 22
Jump Street he is is Patton Oswalt
Albanian I'm not his Patton Oswalt
movies I can movies sometimes I don't
movies but oftentimes I movies is Patton
Oswalt dead check my Wikipedia I guess
is Patton Oswalt a Democrat I am what
Patton Oswalt what Patton Oswalt
what happened to Patton Oswalt carbs
what movies has Patton Oswalt been in
check your IMDB
it starts with down periscope and it
ends with home what college did Patton
Oswalt go to Patton went to the college
of Lehman Mary in Williamsburg Virginia
great place to see drunks and colonial
clothes
what is Patton Oswalt real name Stud
lazer but i changed it for show business
what is Patton Oswalt Halloween costume
this last year was one of the Riddler's
goons and before that I was Ravens demon
father and before that dr. octopus and
next year I'll be dressed as hope
finally who Patton Oswalt whoo Patton
Oswalt whoo
Patton Oswalt voice discord I indeed
beat these you don't have IMDB who is
opening for Patton Oswalt sometimes
young comedian sometimes the who look
they need work who is Patton Oswalt in
agents of shield I'm for different
characters who all look like me and
finally number one who Patton Oswalt's
well this is terrible grammar who Patton
Oswalt's brother who Patton Oswalt's
brother Matt Oswalt brother hey my fans
who are googling me guys I'm flattered
you googled me better than not being
googled that's a bummer